crossover movies like Freddy vs. Jason
or alien versus Predator key characters
from two different franchises and pair
them up establishing the characters of
Co inhabitant of the same cinematic
universe but some movie crossovers are
so subtle you might have missed them
entirely
for example Spy Kids and machete that's
right the gadget creating uncle from
Robert Rodriguez's Spy Kids series as
the same dude who later goes on a
mission for vengeance and blood in the
violence machete and machete kills
movies also helmed by Rodriguez in Spy
Kids under sequels Danny Trejo zonka
machete and his collection of super cool
spy gadgets comes to the aid of the
court has children against a variety of
enemies in 2007 Rodriguez teamed up with
Quentin Tarantino for the horror double
feature grindhouse which had faked
trailers for non-existent movies
including one for machete across the
mulch zombie mysteries after making the
trailer what Regas decided to go ahead
and give uncle machete his own fullness
movie a rare case of PG and r-rated
films sharing the same universe Trading
Places and coming to America in 1983
Trading Places dan Aykroyd and Eddie
Murphy are forced to switch lives
through the orchestrations of the
nefarious Broca brothers Randolph and
Mortimer Duke the movie ends with the
Juke brothers business ruined leaving
them destitute five years later another
Eddie Murphy movie would show us what
became of the Jukes after their downfall
in 1988 coming to America Murphy is a
different character an incredibly
wealthy prince who travels to the United
States in search of a bride who will
love him for who he is rather than for
his money to further that goal the
Prince gives all his remaining money to
a pair of homeless men who turn out
somehow to be the Jukka brothers
or my we're back star wars and ET this
sci-fi crossover was deliberately
planned by both Steven Spielberg and
George Lucas first there's a scene from
et were the kids encounter a kid dressed
in a Yoda costume reminding et of where
he came from
hmm that's obviously not the real
ancient Jedi but he clearly recognizes
the guy the Oberth buddy Lucas returned
the favor in 1999 when he included a
delegation of eg aliens of members of
the Galactic Senate according to an
extended universe novella the aliens are
known as aliens and their leader in the
Senate was named red lips
Spielberg spelled backwards the rules of
attraction and American Psycho if you're
familiar with the source material for
these two very different movies then you
probably already know the connection
between the rules of attraction and
American Psycho both based on Bret
Easton Ellis novels if you're not then
here's a brief explanation james van der
beek Sean Bateman in 2002 the rules of
attraction is actually the younger
brother of Christian Bale
Patrick Bateman from 2000 American
Psycho Patrick was supposed to make a
brief appearance in the rules of
attraction played by another actor but
all of his scenes would cut before the
movie was released the Lone Ranger and
the Green Hornet well it can't be
acknowledged totally today on screen by
either of the characters the Lone Ranger
and the Green Hornet's are actually
related in the early radio serials it
was established that a pretty read The
Green Hornet was the descendant of John
Reed The Lone Ranger depending on the
source
John is described as either Britt's
uncle or great-uncle much later the
properties were sold to different
Studios so the characters can't
intermingle on the big screen but while
movie crossovers are out the comic book
rights are a slightly different story in
2016
dynamite comics obtained the rights of
both characters and the publish to
crossover comic book series that
explores their familial connection
Tarantino's dual cinematic universes for
years
movie fans have speculated that all of
Quentin Tarantino's movies take place
within the same universe and
Teno himself confirmed in 2016 that a
theory is mostly correct there are
actually two universes within his films
one is the real world in which many of
the characters live and the other is the
movie world containing films of the
people in the real world would go and
see as Tarantino explains so when all
the characters of Reservoir Dogs or Pulp
Fiction when they go to the movies Kill
Bill is what they go to see from dusk
till dawn is what they say the logic is
an air-tight but here's just one example
in Pulp Fiction actress Mia Wallace
played by uma Thurman say she wasn't a
TV pilot about female secret agents
where she plays the deadliest woman in
the world with a knife a reference to
Thurman's character the bride in Kill
Bell this means that drug addled Mia
Wallace cleaned up her act to play the
bride within the Tarantino universe
making Kill Bill more than just a
spiritual sequel to Pulp Fiction thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Applause]
you